cristiano ronaldo and his girlfriend
georgina rodriguez have returned home
with their newborn daughter just days
after revealing their little one's twin
brother died
on thursday the couple shared this
family pic on instagram writing home
sweet home before thanking fans for
their kind words and gestures quote your
support is very important and we all
felt the love and respect that you have
for our family
and that respect was on full display
this week as soccer fans took a moment
to applaud and sing in honor of
cristiano's late son
the two concluded their post writing now
it's time to be grateful for the life
that we just welcomed into this world
the 37 year old soccer star first shared
the heartbreaking news on social media
monday writing it is with our deepest
sadness we have to announce that our
baby boy has passed away it is the
greatest pain that any parents can feel
the couple announced that they were
expecting twins back in october sharing
these sonogram photos alongside a
caption that read in part quote our
hearts are full of love we can't wait to
meet you ha ha
momentos bonitos
cristiano and georgina give fans an
inside look at their lives on her
netflix series i am georgina and her
pregnancy was well documented on social
media including this special moment from
their gender reveal party
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
the couple has been together since 2017
and are also parents to alana eva and
matteo and ronaldo is dad to
eleven-year-old cristiano jr
and while the couple mourns the loss of
their son on monday they celebrated the
arrival of their daughter writing only
the birth of our baby girl gives us the
strength to live this moment with some
hope and happiness
and shared this message to their baby
boy quote you are our angel we will
always love you
[Music]
you